- Welcome into another
edition of "Market Takes."
You know, I know you could
have been anywhere in the world
but you're here with me.
I appreciate that.
I am Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
This is "Market Takes."
We are doing a look ahead.
We are gonna talk through, you know,
there's a lot going on in the economy
but there are three big things
that you need to be
watching out for this week.
We are gonna go through
breakdown all of them,
what they are, why they matter,
and what you should be looking out there,
looking out for, this week.
The first is the state of housing.
We have four big reports out this week.
I'm gonna explain what they are
and why each of 'em matters.
Next we have earnings.
Of course, last week, you know,
we got earning season kicked off.
You heard from the big banks
but this week is gonna be
an even more important week of earnings
for the banking sector
and for the economy.
I'm gonna tell you why that is
and what to look out for.
Third, we have, there's been a lot of talk
about the weakening US dollar.
A lot of worries about the
dollar's global prospects
and things like that.
We are gonna talk about
the state of the dollar
and a report that comes out this week
that could tell us a little bit more,
give some context on
the state of the dollar.
So we are gonna talk about
all of that right now.
So let's get into it.
Let's start talking about housing
and why things are getting
better in the housing sector
and why maybe that's
not such a good thing.
So, first charter I wanna
put up here on your screen
is the NAHB Housing Market Index.
Now, we actually just got the
latest update for that report,
out right now at the
start of "Market Takes,"
and that report came in
higher than last month.
Now, you see there on your
screen the last four months,
you see the report just
going up, up, up higher.
Well, it went even
higher April this month.
The last month you see
there is 44 from March,
in April it went up to 45.
So that index just
showing the overall pace
of price increases, of confidence,
of consumers, of builders,
and things like that,
and that has been picking up.
Now you normally think,
"Okay, that's a good thing,
the economy's growing,"
but that might not be such a good thing
because we're seeing all of
the housing market indicators
move in exactly this same direction.
So, that chart there,
illustrating overall
home builder confidence,
and the pace of increases in prices,
we are seeing that
exact same kind of trend
where things have been
moving lower, lower, lower.
The Fed raised interest rates,
they're trying to slow down the economy.
They want consumers
to reconsider their purchasing decisions,
not take on more credit.
And that's they want, they
wanna see things come down,
and get lower, and get worse.
And so there's less confidence,
less borrowing, less spending.
But that's not what we've seen
the past three months,
going all the way back.
And now past four or five months,
all the way through December of last year,
we have seen a pickup and an increase,
and that continued in April.
Now, we're also seeing
that in housing starts,
we get the latest housing
starts data on Tuesday.
That last month accelerated 9.8%,
almost 10% month over month.
That was the fastest pace in September.
Home construction also.
Home construction had been trending lower,
and those housing starts number tells us
about what builders are doing,
they're actually starting
housing projects.
That picked up in a big
way, almost 10% last month.
We will see if that continues tomorrow.
A big piece of that was multi-family,
which we know is people putting money,
investing in units for renting out
rather than for living.
We also get the mortgage,
the MBA's Weekly Mortgage
Application Survey.
Last week, the 30-year
fixed rate fell a 6.3%,
the lowest level in two months.
And we saw applications for
mortgages increase by 8%.
Mike Fratantoni, he is the SVB
and the chief economist of the SVP.
Excuse me, senior vice president
at the Mortgage Bankers Association,
and their chief economist.
He said that prospective
home buyers this year
have been quite sensitive to
any drop in mortgage rates.
Mortgage rates dropping a 6.3%.
Now, that's a little lower,
but remember a year or two ago
you saw mortgage rates down
about that three handle,
and we getting up to the four handle.
Now mortgage rates, still
high, still at 6.3%,
but you're seeing housing starts pick up.
You're seeing mortgage
applications pick up.
And everything the Fed is doing
to try to slow the economy
is kind of being undone,
slowly but surely.
Remember, mortgages,
mortgage rates, housing,
all those things, were the
first thing to slow down
when the Fed first started
raising interest rates.
Now they're starting to pick back up,
as the Fed is expected to slow down
its interest rate hiking cycle.
The markets are showing
one more expected increase
in May next month and then
cuts starting in July.
Well, consumers are responding,
taking on more mortgages, more debts,
and we're seeing housing
starts to pick back up.
We've seen the housing
market index pick back up.
We also will get the
existing home sales report
out on Thursday.
Last month we saw Existing
Home Sales rise by almost 15%.
We are gonna be right here Thursday,
breaking down the Existing
Home Sales report,
telling you why that happens.
That could be a big market mover
because existing homes
are most of the economy,
or most of the market,
when it comes to mortgages.
So be with us right here on
"Market Takes" Thursday at noon,
we'll break all that down.
Now let's talk about
earnings really quickly.
Last week we had bank
earnings for the big banks,
JPMorgan, Citigroup, Wells Fargo,
all big, booming blowout earnings.
JPMorgan said profit was up
52% in the first quarter,
a $38.3 billion in revenue.
Wells Fargo, $5 billion,
Citigroup, $4.6 billion.
PNC Bank, another big one, $1.7 billion.
These are huge, big booming numbers.
JPMorgan shares actually rose 7.5%,
that was the number one stock
in the S&P 500 on Friday.
And then you had Citigroup
up 5%, 4.8%, the second best,
the second biggest increase
in the overall S&P 500.
But let's throw something
up here on your screen.
I wanna put that number, or
those numbers, in context
so you can see just how much
folks in the investing community
are really responding to that.
That huge drop happened after SVB,
and you see that there at
the edge of your screen.
That's the Friday response.
So investors, okay, well,
banks are doing a little bit better.
And remember this index you're seeing
is mostly the big banks.
It's mostly Citigroup,
it's mostly JPMorgan,
Bank of America.
Even those big blowout earnings
weren't enough to really
get investors excited
about the banks.
And you see a little
pickup, but not that much.
So that just illustrates
that investors are not sold
that banks are back.
There is still a lot of worry
about the banking sector.
And we will find out this week.
We get reports from Ally, Fifth Third,
M&T Bank, Western Alliance, Zion, KeyBank,
some of these regional banks
that are the ones most in trouble.
We saw JPMorgans's CFO,
Jeremy Barnum, said
there's about $50 billion
of deposit inflows
in the first quarter.
That's largely coming
from those regional banks.
We are gonna find out how those
regional banks did this week
and expect the numbers to not be so great,
and that could cause another
selloff in the market.
Look out for that.
We also get earnings from
Johnson & Johnson, Netflix,
Tesla, United Airlines, and a big one
I think is gonna be Schwab.
Those earnings are gonna be key.
Watch out for that.
Last thing we wanna talk
about here on "Market Takes"
is the weak dollar.
There's been all kinds of talk about this,
folks have been worried.
News headlines popping up here and there.
Also, you've seen Secretary
of the Treasury, Janet Yellen,
gave an interview where
she was asked directly
about the state of the dollar.
So, wanna throw something
on your screen here,
really quickly, to just show
you the movement overall.
You see there, the dollar
is clearly down this year
but that movement has been up and down,
and you see at the edge of
your screen there on the right,
picking back up.
Investors are very strongly
positioned right now,
speculative investors, for a big pickup
and an increase in the dollar this year,
their position net long on the dollar
against just about every other
major currency out there.
So, that chart illustrating
the overall positioning
right now, that we've seen,
we've seen the dollar
decline a little bit.
It's weaker, but historically
not that big a move.
I wanna read you a real quick
quote from Secretary Yellen.
She said, quote, "There is a risk
when we use financial sanctions
that are linked to the role of the dollar,
that over time it could undermine
the hegemony of the dollar."
What that means is the
value of the dollar,
the ability and the
omnipresence of the dollar
in global financial systems,
there's a risk there.
We've seen talk from China, from Russia,
there's been a long-term
push against the dollar
because they don't want the United States
to be able to sanction them
to cause economic pain.
If they don't use the dollar,
well, the US can't cut them
outta the banking system,
et cetera, et cetera.
But, as you saw from that chart,
the dollar has declined
in value a little bit,
but investors not buying that story,
thinking, "Okay, the
dollar's power and strength
is gonna come back,"
and that over the course
of time, over the course,
even of this year, we'll be back.
We are at historically-strong
levels for the dollar
and folks are thinking,
"Okay, that dollar strength
is gonna come back because
maybe interest rates
are picking up."
This really is a story more
about the Federal Reserve
and central banks,
and the expectation for
the European Central Bank
to raise rates more than the Fed.
This isn't about people
not using the dollar
or the dollar going away.
Just wanted to make that clear.
And this week we will hear from the Fed.
The Fed's beige book is out on Wednesday.
That's gonna tell us how the Fed
is seeing the overall economy.
They talk to a lot of
businesses and they say,
"Hey, what's going on in
your district and your area?"
We will get that report on Wednesday.
Listen, that's gonna do it
for us here on "Market Takes."
Like I said, I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but
you were here with me,
and I appreciate that.
Thursday we'll be breaking down
the Existing Home Sales Report at noon.
Be here or be a, that's
a square, don't do it.
Listen, that's gonna do
it from "Market Takes."
I'm Dion Rabouin, reporter
at the Wall Street Journal.
We will see you next time.